[MUSIC]
What's up everyone, headed to school.
>> Good morning.
[MUSIC]
>> I'm being reminded of the honor
given to me to be studying here.
[MUSIC]
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
I am here at the Stanford Design School.
>> Yeah.
>> Hi.
>> What are your thoughts
about that locally?
>> Okay, so let's start.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]
>> My God.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> Let's go.
GSB in one word, what do you think?
>> Eclectic.
>> Great advice.
>> It's lunchtime.
>> Hey, what's up, everyone?
>> Good, good, good, and you?
>> What percentage of your capability as a
human being you feel you are able to bring
to that job?
>> [LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> Mine's cool, look at this place.
>> [LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> We are making our own
virtual reality headsets.
>> Beautiful [INAUDIBLE] day.
>> [LAUGH] Keep going.
Keep going.
>> I don't know about you,
but I love palm trees.
[MUSIC]
>> And
our guest today is Reese Witherspoon.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]
>> Change the world one step at a time.
>> [LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> What are you talking about?
Temporary non-calls.
[MUSIC]
Small group dinners
>> Yeah.
>> For the past year you've walked
everyday past the cornerstone of the GSB
campus that states that we as a school
are dedicated to the things that haven't
happened yet.
And to the people who
are about to dream them out.
>> You can do anything.
Do what you really want to do.
>> Here at the GSB, you have committed
yourself to becoming principled and
insightful leaders.
Determined not only to
change organizations,
but to change lives and change the world.
[MUSIC]
>> Like this, 360 days out of 365.